وصلت الطفله ميرال الى المستشفى تريد
اباها ولم تعلم انها صارت يتيمه ابوها
وامها قتل في الهجوم الاسرائيلي
الطفله بحاجه لتدخل نفسي عاجل هي وثمانون
في المئه من اطفال غزه وفق منظمه انقذوا
الاطفال الدوليه ست حروب سابقه على غزه
تركت اثار النفسيه مدمره على اطفالها
الحروب المستمره على قطاع غزه لابد ان
تترك اثارا انيه واثار بعيده المدى
بالنسبه للاثار الانيه وخلال الساعات
والايام القادمه قد يرى الاهالي مجموعه من
الاعراض تظهر على ابنائهم الخوف الشديد
نوبات من الهلع عدم قدره على النوم او حتى
تقيؤ غير مفهوم السبب او حتى اشكال اخرى
من الاضطرابات في الجهاز الهضمي اذا ما
اعتبرت ميرال من الناجين فان علي وميار
وهاجر لم ينجو قتلتهم الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه وهم في فراشهم وامسوا وقود
حرب لا ترحم
اكثر من 2000 طفل قتلوا خلال السنوات
العشرين الاخيره
ذنبهم الوحيد انهم ولدوا في غزه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات